Okay, so we are recording now and it was like last time, real briefly, just state
your name and date date.
Yeah, my name is Kenneth Hadberg and what else you want?
Date, date.
Date, date?
Yeah.
Oh, and this is September 20, 2011.
So we last thought last time you had just made this switch over to the energy maker and
you were studying your research with him.
I wanted to think about how that happened how you met your maker and started out on
that subject.
This is that Caltech.
I can't remember whether I mentioned it, I spent a year working with Gardeners Wayne.
I think I did that.
Yeah.
Well, at the end of that time, I interviewed a boarder-shamaker who might pass them them all
several times and he had a group of people.
He was young, not far from my age.
So I went to see him.
We hit it off.
Well, and I decided I would do my future work with him.
And I began almost immediately and we decided we would look at a number of boron compounds
that we were able to...
We didn't make them ourselves.
We got them from a guy at USC who's...
Name, I can't remember now, distinguished in organic chemicals today, right?
And we began with Diborane, which we measured and were able to show conclusively that it was
a non-ethane-like structure.
It had two hydrogens up above and below the boron-boron bond and the well-known bridge structure.
After that, we took up a number of other boron compounds, including B4H10, B5H9, B5H11,
and some substituted Diborane with chlorine and bromine atoms on them and also amino groups,
amino Diborane, we studied all of these to place in the next few years.
I think some of them overlapped.
I was still working when some of them after I got my degree when I continued.
So that was an exciting time.
And excuse me.
I finished my degree in June of 1948 and I was offered a postdoctoral position.
Oh, that came about in an interesting way.
Pauline came around one time in spring of 1947.
That was only, or maybe it was a fall of 1947.
I'd only been there for at most 18 months and he said,
I think you should write up your work for a degree.
And I said, well, I was hoping I would be able to take another year and work that year
with Professor Badger, who is a distinguished spectroscopist.
Pauline said to me, well, he says, you write up your thesis and get a degree and I'll
see that you get a fellowship so you can spend an extra year working with Dick Badger.
And then he said, you know, you'll make a lot more money after you get your degree than
you would before you get your degree.
So why not?
Your studying doesn't stop at the time you get your degree.
So the logic of this was impeccable and I said about writing up my work for my thesis.
And I'm sorry about this thought I had the same problem last time.
So I finished writing up my thesis.
Now the troublesome aspect of this is that my supervisor, Werder Schumacher, was off
on the Guggenheim Fellowship in Denmark.
And so the person that nominally oversaw my research was Robert Cory.
Robert Cory, of course, he and Pauline published a series of seven papers that ultimately led
to Pauline's winning in Nobel Prize for his Alpha Helix and other things as well.
Anyway, Bob Cory didn't know anything about electron diffraction, but he was a very nice
friendly man and he helped me over some crucial points.
So I said, I'm having a lot of trouble writing this thesis, getting it all right.
He says, well, he says, tell me what it is you're struggling with.
And so I told him, he said, well, why don't you write it down?
So I wrote down what I had been telling him and then edited a little bit and I don't
get me over home.
Anyway, I finally finished my thesis and took my examination.
Pauline was not present in Werder, was not present either, having it still being in Denmark.
So, excuse me.
Before I got my degree, I continued to work for a while on the projects that I had been
working until Werder returned to Denmark.
And then I was sure enough, I've got my degree polling returned and I received notice that
I had been awarded an A-Noise Fellowship which enabled me to spend a year working with
Richard Badger.
Which I did and I learned some spectroscopy in that year.
But on the side I continued my work in electron diffraction as well.
Well, that was a very nice year.
At the end of my fellowship year, I was appointed a research fellow at Caltech and I worked
on a grant that Werder Schumacher had with the Office of Neville Research.
At that time, the Office of Neville Research was sponsoring basic research.
I didn't have to have much to do with the Navy as far as I could make up.
So I worked on that for a couple of years.
And then in 1951, I think it was polling said to me, oh, maybe I should go back a step.
During this year, a number of people showed up at Caltech from abroad, mostly post-doctoral
people who were anxious to work either with polling or some other dignitary and Werder
Schumacher, Werder Schumacher.
And I became quite friendly with a number of these people, including a guy from Norway
named Ulte Bustjonsen.
I'm getting just a little ahead of the story there.
Because I decided after I'd had a couple of years that I should have a post-doctoral fellowship
maybe abroad or something like that.
So I decided that I would continue my work in spectroscopy.
And so I filled out an application for a full-bright fellowship to Belgium.
There was a man there with whom I wanted to work.
And so I filled this thing out, sent it all off, and got back a notice and do course a
few months later, saying unfortunately.
My application had been received too late to be considered in that year's batch of
full-bright fellows, but they urged me to apply again for the following year.
Well in the following year, my friend Ulte Bustjonsen, later friend Ulte Bustjonsen, showed
up from Norway, and he was a specialist in Electro-Nepraxion.
And I had known him not personally, but through publications.
And we hit it off.
We became very friendly with my wife and myself and him and his wife, and he had two small
daughters.
And so we worked together at Caltech for a while.
And then, as your daughter of close, he said, why don't you apply again for a full-bright
and apply this time to go to Norway instead of to Belgium?
I said, well, that sounds to me like it might be worthwhile.
Maybe I'll do that.
About the same time Pauline walked into my office one day and said to me, I think you
should apply for a Guggenheim fellowship.
This is how he didn't say, would you like to?
He said, I think you should do this.
Well Pauline carried such an oral with him that when he made a suggestion, you almost
always followed through and decided that was a prestigious fellowship.
And so I thought, gulped and said, okay, I'll do that.
So I wrote out an application form, which was essentially the same proposal for research
that I had written to the full-bright program.
And I sent this off.
And I waited around a while, working away with Werner, not knowing what was going to happen.
The meantime, Bustjansson went back to Norway.
And in due course, I got a letter from the full-bright people saying that I had been awarded
a full-bright research fellowship to go to Norway.
And this paid all my living expenses and paid my transportation back and forth.
And then about that same time, maybe a little later, Pauline walked into my office and said
to me, well, are you getting ready to go to Norway?
And he didn't know anything about my having received the full-bright fellowship.
And I said, well, I didn't know I was going.
And I think I may have the chronology inverted here a little bit.
I think maybe he came in before I received notice of the full-bright fellowship.
That makes a little more sense in what he's back.
I said, I didn't know I was going.
He said, well, the selection committee generally follows my recommendations and he turned and walked out.
That's all, that was a total conversation we had on the issue.
And a bit later, I got a letter from the good and high people saying I had been awarded a good and high fellowship to go to Norway.
And it was $3,500.
Well, now, and then the full-bright notice occurred.
And then I had gone from where I had no support, where I had two rather well-endowed fellowships for the same period.
So I thought, well, you know, I have to let them know.
So I rolled off to the good and high people, said I'd also been awarded a full-bright fellowship research fellowship.
They said the good and high money was given to me, irrespective of whatever other awards or monies I had.
Well, I felt pretty good about that.
So well, of course, I set the same letter to the full-bright people.
And they wrote back after a while and said, we normally subtract money from additional grants from the full-bright grant.
But that, the amount of money that you have from the other source should be enough to support you for the full period of your time before we will take any action on this.
And they said, we have determined that the $3,500, this is in 1942, that went a long way then, that $3,500 is not enough to support you in Norway for a full 12 months.
So we will not subtract it from the amount that we give you for the full-bright grant.
So the full-bright grant was the equivalent of a little more money than that, actually.
I can't remember what it was in Kroner.
I think it was 4,200 Kroner a month, and there were seven Kroner to the dollar then.
So that was about $600 a month.
That might have been $75,000, and over 10,000 bucks in those days were big bucks.
Well, at this time, my first wife decided that she met somebody she preferred to me, and so she let me, and I had all this money, that was going to go to Norway with as a single person.
So I booked passage on Mauritania, and I traveled across the country, visited a couple of laboratories, I went to Oak Ridge and visited some friends there, went on to New York, sent my luggage on ahead, and due course, I embarked on the Mauritania, which took me to Southampton.
And I spent a few days in England, and then I set sail again on another ship to Norway.
And when I arrived there, this was an origin ship liner.
I was met at the pier by my friend, Ultima Steeleinson, and a number of other people that I had met there.
I didn't mention that I had been to Norway once before, after I had met Boss Johnson, I went to an international meeting in Stockholm.
And on the way back, I stopped, so I'll buy and shout out to him a little bit about what we were going to do.
We had a big party.
That was a fine party.
I can still remember it.
I don't know whether I should go into the details there, but anyway, that was a great party.
So he and his friends and collaborators in the laboratory met me at the boat, and they had been looking for a place for me to live.
This was Norway in 1950, the October of 1952, first of October.
And it was after the war, and Norway hadn't really begun to recover very much then.
So they told me that they had found an apartment, and they were ashamed to say it was terribly expensive.
But they thought it would suit me pretty well because it was very close to shopping.
I had a...
Oh, let me call it a district anyway, called Mayush to it.
And I had a fine apartment there, and it was owned by an English woman who had been separated or divorced from her husband.
She had gotten this apartment.
She was going back to England where she came from originally and was going to rent it out for a year.
So, and it cost my friends to tell me that some of the much over price was 150 crore a month.
That's $20.
Now, 150 crore remember, my first check was 4,200 crore.
And that paid my rent for the entire month.
And...
So anyway, I moved into this place, which was furnished.
It had a kind of a couch or a bed, but it was perfectly satisfactory and had a kitchen, a bath and all of that.
Kind of a studio arrangement.
Within walking, the easy walking distance of the university up on the hill.
So, I lived there and I had determined before I left that I was going to learn the language.
And my friends, Bustjonsson, had been talking to the cultural attaché at the embassy and to the people in charge of the full-by program.
And they had managed to find me a set of records called, and those that are no longer existent, I think,
they had an extended call, a lingua-phone records.
And they got me, they were 78s.
And they got me an old record player.
A friend had one of those and so I could play these records on them, they could hear the sound.
Along with these records came a book.
And this book had a picture on it.
And it had the text that was spoken.
So, the idea was that you put the record on.
The lesson, of course, was almost obvious.
The words were ones that you could transliterate from English.
So, very slowly the words were spoken on this page.
And you could see the picture of what it was describing on the facing page.
And so, I would look at this and the spoken word would come to you.
And then there would be a pause.
And you were supposed to repeat after this, mimicking the accent, the tonality as closely
as you could.
And so, this, I later came to admire these records very much because at the same time you
saw the written language.
You heard it spoken and you had to speak it.
And there was no translation except in the picture.
And believe it or not, this happened in 52.
I can still recite lesson 123 almost by heart because after you had gone through this thing,
there was another section where they were asked, you were asked the question relating to
this.
And you had to respond to that.
You see, it was quite remarkable.
And an example of this, the first sentence was describing the picture, it was,
Deette Art Familia Hansen.
Now, you can almost say what that, Norwegian is a language which has almost the same word
order as English.
Deette Art means this is.
And this is the family Hansen in this picture.
And then they say, best of all, sit there, in, in a stool.
Grandfather is sitting in a walking chair.
And you could see that if you know, at the bottom it says best of all, it says, Grandfather
is here, look in a picture and there's an old man, you know, the beard.
And he's sitting, sit there, you know, that right away, in, in, in, in a stool, you
know where they learn that stool is chair and then it means rocker.
Anyway, that's just an example.
And I went through, every day I came back from the university, I would sit down, I would
study, it's amazing.
These things only played for three minutes if you played them through.
It took me an hour and an hour and a half to get through a single lesson doing everything
they wanted me to do.
And in the morning I would go up to the university and I would, my friends saw, you know, they knew
I was doing this and I could recite the whole lesson to them which caused proxisms of laughter.
One of my friends said the guy, there were several voices, as the lessons went on.
The first was a man who had a, he was an Norwegian but he was a rector of the university
at that time.
And my friends swore they could hear his voice speaking when I spoke to them, I mean mimic
this accent.
Well anyhow, when I first went up to the laboratory to meet Paul Stjohnson in a work environment
and we talk, we knew what we were going to do.
He introduced me to his laboratory assistant, whose name was Lisa Snavić.
And he said, she's only been working with the three months but I think you two should
work together because I am an administrative duties I'm occupied with also.
So we engaged in this project and Lisa and I worked on it together.
Well when I was introduced to her I was ever so impressed because of course I was introduced
in English on the first day or two and she spoke to me in English and we had a conversation
and I later asked, well have you spent any time and what did you learn in your English?
She said, well I learned it in school, I said, haven't you been to England or the states?
Oh no, no, she says, I've never been in an English speaking country.
It impressed me so much and this is true all these people, you know.
You walk in, they've never been out of that country they can talk to you in your language.
I'm sure those can do that here, it's almost impossible.
Anyway we worked together for two or three days and then I, very interested in music
and the also Philharmonic played downtown and I got on the tram one time when I was on
the town.
Oh I think, oh in the first few days I was there I decided I needed to have my own car.
There were very few cars and also at that time.
My use to it today is one of the busiest places in town.
I mean it's bumper to bumper getting through there.
When I lived there it was rarely a car and they were all pre-war things.
The country was so destitute of so devoid of money that cars were very, very hard to
come by.
But anyway I could buy a car, there were agencies there but I had to pay for it and for
it and see and I had to agree to sell it.
I mean I had to agree to export the car.
It had a special license plate on it in the case.
It had a Q number on it which means owned by a foreigner and means you didn't buy tax.
So the upside of all this was that if I sold the car in the country at the end tax would
have to be paid on it at that stage.
Anyway I bought this car.
So I drove the downtown to go to the symphony here a few weeks later and as I walked in
there stood Lisa picking up her ticket as I was picking up mine so we sat together,
enjoyed the symphony and afterward I asked her if she'd like to have a after concert snack.
And so we went to a restaurant of famous place called Blooms that is still there and we
had a big cheese spread and had a good time together and we again date regularly.
And the upshot of all that was that after my year there I went back to the States and
there was Lisa and I were thinking of getting married and I wasn't quite ready to commit
because I hadn't quite recovered from my first marriage.
But at any rate I got back to the States and then I proposed to her and I came back to
the following summer which is 54 and we were married in Oslo and that say 54 I guess
we've now been married 57 years.
Anyhow that was a romantic outcome and I got I've often speculated about this later
as suppose that full bright application that I had applied for to Holland to Belgium had
been successful.
My life would have been quite different from what it is now.
Such things, fate turns on.
Were there any colleges that you're family?
How do you mean marrying a fair foreigner?
Her mother had died a couple of years before I arrived.
She had a sister and a father.
A father worked in a bank, a personal manager of a bank and she had an aunt, sister of her
mother that lived upstairs in the apartment building.
My wife's family is going back to generations as a distinguished one.
They came from Denmark and my wife's great-great-grandfather was the foreign minister of Denmark.
He and one of his siblings founded the New York Times of Denmark.
It's called Poulotique and so the family had an interest in that newspaper.
One of the other brothers was a distinguished newspaper, my name is Critique.
The name is well-known.
It's called Brandes.
Edvard Brandes, you can find books written about the Brandes family in Denmark.
Well, that was her great-great-grandfather and great-great-great uncle.
So anyway, Alicia's mother's stand from this group has did her aunt upstairs who became
kind of a surrogate mother to her after her own mother died.
So, we came back.
Alicia's father.
I enjoyed him a lot.
He was very taciturn.
Some Norwegians don't say very much but I think he was pleased that I could speak to him
in his language.
He didn't know.
He could speak a few words in some words of English but he wasn't as comfortable in it.
So we hit it off very well.
And Alicia's aunt too, she was a patrician, tight person.
She had beautiful furniture and paintings and so on.
Her husband was a distinguished Norwegian scholar and so on.
Very wealthy.
And this family, Lisa's aunt, uncle and her cousin to whom she is still very close.
We see them quite often.
They have a lot of fancy stuff.
They have paintings by Toulouse with track and they have monk originals.
They have a lot of gold, watercolors and lithographs and so on in their house.
That's just something on the wall and I would put an impress by all that.
So after we were married, I...
What, like, you know, did you have it in the evening?
No.
We married in the city hall in Norway.
You haven't been in Norway, have you?
Well, they have an absolutely beautiful city hall and it's got marvelous paintings around
that huge murals on the wall that depict the development and evolution of the Norwegian nation.
And outside they have some carved, huge carved wooden figures from Northeastern mythology.
The wooden is there on his eight-legged horse with two ravens ahead, all in wood you
can see up there.
So no, we were married.
They said a reinstall license before I arrived and we were married in this office.
It was a civil wedding.
I'm not sure, but I think as far as I know, a lot of the Norwegian weddings are done in
that fashion, at least, of the generation that Lisa stems from.
So after we were married, we fussed around a while because we had to get a visa for her.
And that's a story which irritates me still.
So we applied for a visa, I had done at the embassy.
The embassy is very worried that there are foreigners that want to marry American citizens
simply to get into the country.
Then you have to jump through a whole bunch of hoops.
And time went on, one week turned into two, turned into three, and so on.
And no word, no word at all.
And so I finally wrote to a friend of mine that I met at Caltech and then was working
with him and he was working in Washington.
And I explained the situation to him.
And he pulled some strings and discovered that the application was sitting on the desk someplace
in a pile of papers and they were working through and they would get to it.
So I virtually blew my top at this because here I am sitting in Oslo and not getting paid
because I'm not working, waiting for some secretary to clear my application for a visa.
So I wrote to my congressman in Pasadena and he wrote back on other dismissal, dismissive
letters saying we have to make absolutely certain that these marriages are not marriages
of convenience.
And you can imagine how I felt about it.
He was a conservative Republican.
I probably turned me into a Democrat forever, but anyhow.
Eventually we got to the visa.
We got on the plane, flew to Washington, spent a night there and went on to Pasadena.
And my wife was very tired at this time and discouraged.
And when Norway had beautiful atmospheric conditions, you could breathe deeply and the sky
was clear.
And we landed in a heavy smog time in LA and she later says she felt like getting right
back on the next plane and going home without experience.
So we stayed there and I went back to work at Caltech as a senior research fellow now
and continued until I learned about the job I'd already been stayed.
Now shall I go on to that?
Well I have more questions about Caltech.
I'll take a little bit more in this.
So it sounds to me like the first thing you have is that trust be was what she made
it accurate?
No, it was Dick Badger.
I did an electron the fraction with Schumaker, which is a different technique.
Some people call it electron spectroscopy, but it is not.
I'm sorry.
Can it be bundled under the heading of crystallography or is that a separate discipline?
It's a separate discipline, but it's similar to the crystallography in the sense that you
measure a diffraction pattern.
The diffraction patterns are very, very different because I'm looking at molecules in the
gas and x-ray diffraction looks at molecules and it is in a crystal or at least in a condensed
phase.
So how would you classify your discipline in the field?
Well, how do you mean classify it?
It's a technique for studying the sizes and shapes of individual molecules.
So would you call yourself a physical chemistry with infrastructural chemistry?
So I guess I'm wondering at what point did you decide this is something you want to pursue
at the beginning?
Well, when I was a Caltech, as I say, I started doing organic reaction mechanisms for a year.
Then I did electron diffraction.
And in the course of this, I did some crystal structure with two other people.
Then I did spectroscopy with Dick Badger, so I had four different experiences there.
Now, this is a little unusual because at this institution, it's rare that a student works
for more than one person in the course of getting his or her degree.
Usually you pick a supervisor and you work on his projects and what up with thesis and
you're out of here.
When I worked in end-mythesis, the Badger worked, of course, I was a post-cultural fellow at that time.
But in the course of getting my degree, I did three things and all of these things were
written up in my thesis in different sections.
That's a little unusual, probably a little unusual for Caltech too, in that people often do
two different things.
But three with three different people is quite different.
I don't know whether I mentioned that.
The crystal structure was very interesting.
It had to do with a compound called Arsino benzene, which has a formula,
which I can describe verbally as two benzene rings and two arsenic atoms.
It was generally thought that the benzene rings are hooked to the arsenic atoms and two arsenic
atoms are joined together by a double bond, as we say in the language.
But it was pretty well understood at that time that arsenic doesn't like to form double bonds very readily.
And particularly with a compound like this, where there's no opportunity, for example,
of no oxygen, so round to form double bonds.
So it was widely thought to be a dimer, the one I described, just two units hooked together.
But we suspected that wasn't true, and so when we looked at it, we found that there actually was a six-member
ring of arsenic atoms with these benzene rings flopping off, one off of each arsenic atom.
So it was a hexamer, really, and a very nice molecule.
The interesting thing about this is, many years later, I got a photocopy,
and a large photocopy, which I still have.
This is before Euro became the official currency of Europe.
I have a 200-mark German banknote.
Now 200 marks is a big bucks in those days.
And on it is a picture, a man who is responsible for discovering first arsenic holes in use
for treating syphilis in particular.
Well, one of the arsenic holes used was, I gather, was arsenic menacing,
because on this banknote, our paper is actually cited with the three authors and the date,
which happens to be wrong, but at any rate, it's on the face of the banknote.
I thought that was lots of fun.
So, anyway, that's what I did at Caltech.
And I called myself a structure chemist.
So the thing that led me into electron diffraction was,
I had to realize this was 50 odd years ago now,
it was kind of a cutting-edge technology.
It was the best way, everything considered,
of determining the sizes and shapes and motions of individual molecules
that are unaffected by the presence of others.
A crystal structure, of course, of molecules that will affect the other.
And the other technique that works also on the same phase is microinspectroscopy.
But in order for microinspectroscopy to succeed,
it has to, molecule has to have a dipole moment, and a lot of them don't.
Arsenobenzine, for example, would not have.
So you can't study a lot of things, but we can study anything we can get into the gas phase.
Select on the fraction.
So, I decided I would continue with that work,
because I like what I was doing with Schumacher at Caltech.
And that's what got me started.
So you think some Schumacher and Cori are just knowing a little bit more about what they were like,
because their personalities were like the foods that they were doing socially?
Well, I can tell you, well Schumacher,
he was in my way of thinking he was a brilliant scientist, but not aggressive in the sense that he pushed like a lot of people do.
You know, in science, it isn't always enough to have talent.
You have to be a salesman as well.
And people like Lina's Paul Engel, he is a tremendous salesman, because he had a personality that took in the whole room.
So he had a sense of humor in these lectures where very, very heavily attended.
People had come from miles around to here, and I've heard him lecture to packed halls in several foreign countries.
There are other people who are distinguished also, but have a very tiring personality.
And some of these are one noble prizes, but they don't have a public acclaim that a person like Paul Engel's or Ahmed Suleil does from Caltech.
And these guys sell themselves, you know, and there are other people too.
So Schumacher was a brilliant scientist and a very critical thinker.
He was amazing in that respect.
He was so highly regarded that Paul Engel used to come down and bounce his ideas off of Schumacher.
He would come into the office, you know, and talk to Schumacher and say,
they've earned her what do you think of this, and he would describe something.
And other people, the organic chemists from the third floor of Caltech,
names are getting harder for me to come by quickly, would come down, talk to him about various problems they had.
And he was like a bulldog. He couldn't let go of a problem.
He would analyze it, turn it around upside down, and if this, that, etc. etc.
These people were sitting listening very carefully to him.
So that's a kind of guy I was.
He also, we went hiking in the Sierra backpacking together.
We became close personal friends, as well as my me being his student.
So we did hikes in the high Sierra's on a couple of occasions.
I used to go every summer for, anyway, one to two weeks backpacking in the high Sierra.
So we would do that.
And he was eager and interested in that.
There are a host of interesting events.
But you see, I'm not quite sure how much of this I should go into.
But let me talk about Cori.
Cori was a, he was a very nice man, and he helped me a great deal when Schumacher wasn't there in that last year when I was riding up my thesis.
And he was a crystallographer.
And I don't remember the details, so I won't try to recite them.
But I've read them.
You can get them the archives, Caltech archives, tell all about polling, encountering Cori and inviting him to come to Caltech.
So at any rate, he suffered from some kind of a nervous disorder.
It was not Parkinson's in that he had some ticks that would cause his whole arm to move a little bit.
And when he walked, he walked sometimes with a little bit of motion.
I'm not quite sure what it was, but that was not evident in his speech when you talked to him.
And when he was sitting down, you didn't see any Parkinson's like motion at all for me.
But he would come to see me, and I could see him in a time I wanted.
He was responsible for a very large, excuse me, laboratory.
He was headed up by a guy who was making compounds of the sort that polling was interested in that played a role ultimately in his formulation of the Alpha Helix.
I don't know much more about him than just that.
But to this day, I'm very grateful for what he did for me in the time of Schimmick's absence.
Do you know Dan Campbell?
Yes.
Dan was a very nice guy to me and a very nice wife.
I knew Dan Campbell quite well because there was a very free social order at Caltech.
All kinds of parties with the students, postdocs and the faculty.
You have a student party, you know, and everybody would be invited and Dick Badger would show up with his wife and Dan and his wife would show up.
And others as well.
Polling didn't come to these parties as far as I know.
I don't remember ever seeing him there, but I do remember a number of them in which people from physics can Dick Feynman showed up in a number of these.
I heard Feynman play his bongo drums at these parties.
So Campbell was a nice guy.
He had a medical problem which was solved.
He had colon cancer and they removed a large tumor from his colon.
But I don't think he ever suffered a recurrence of that.
He was what was called an immunochemus.
And that was something that Polling was interested in at the time, immunochemistry.
So does that answer your question about what I knew about Campbell?
Did you ever buy any chance to eat Roger Hayward?
Yes.
No.
But only in passing.
Roger Hayward, of course, was illustrating Polling books for him.
And he had a number of beautiful figures in various books.
But only in passing, I just met him.
And he was the talker.
We have Hayward's papers.
We also have the papers of Jack Demitz.
Well, do you?
Yes.
Yeah, I guess you told me that last time.
I'm interested in knowing a little bit more about Jack with it.
And then the person and also why is he important among scientists?
Oh.
Well, I didn't talk about Jack before.
Did I?
No.
Jack was a, became a very, I'm just to this day, a very good friend of mine.
He showed up after getting his degree at, in Scotland, with Jim Robertson.
And he came to Caltech.
And in the British system, you know, when you study for a PhD, you do your undergraduate work.
You study for a PhD.
But my understanding is you don't do much coursework from that point on.
So Jack attended lectures at Caltech.
You see, on subjects that he had an interest in that he had not been exposed to before.
But we worked together a little bit.
We published a paper together.
And Jack has an absolutely incredible sense of humor.
And he could do, I don't know.
He's not a pushy guy.
It's kind of a laid back, why sense of humor, you know.
But he's not a retiring individual at all.
He's a very social guy.
He's just not a pushy social guy.
So he came to Caltech and he was working on crystallography, on an electron diffraction.
And then he was joined by, I won't say he was joined, but another guy came named Leslie Orgel.
And Jack and Leslie became very good friends.
Leslie, he died recently, but he was a distinguished scientist.
He was a theoretical chemist to begin with, but began to turn to molecular biology later on.
And went to the Salk Institute and had a distinguished career there.
Jack, when Pauline won his Nobel Prize for chemistry in 54, we had a huge big...
And then we put together, let's call it a review in the Valdivale sort of thing,
where there are lots of skits and songs.
And there was a talented fellow named Ted Herald also from Britain, who could write music and played the piano.
And he composed a lot of stuff.
And among other things that were composed were little acts for a participant who would do a kind of monologue.
And Jack was involved in one of these.
That's a famous one.
The whole thing has been recorded.
You probably have a copy of it here. It's called the Road to Stockholm.
In there, there's something where one of the individuals sitting in his laboratory looking out the window at the young girls going by,
in front of a cold Bunsen, as Jack puts it.
If you haven't heard that record, it should be put on tape or a disc because it's on Shalak and homemade,
and it tends to deteriorate.
So, Jack participated in things like that.
Then a young lady came
and they began to go together. Her name was Daphne.
I don't remember her last name.
But at any rate, they became very close and they became engaged to be married.
She was a post-doctoral person working in biology.
And they had met at one of these social occasions, I guess, and they were together a lot in groups,
and they had a lot of big parties all of this work.
And then, Jack's period, Daphne went home, and Jack's period at Celtic ended, and he went home.
And then it turned out that she had decided against the marriage and broke the engagement.
Well, Jack at this time was working with Dorothy Hodgkin and Oxford.
And I was on a trip to Europe for some meeting or another, and I stopped by and visited with Jack.
And he told me that it was really a hard thing for him.
But it turned out, Daphne never married after that.
We're not quite sure.
And the reason that they broke up, it's a little obscure, but I can say this, at least as a rumor,
she decided that Jack was Jewish, his Jewish, and she was not.
And this conflict, religious conflict, apparently, was something she decided she couldn't live with.
At any rate, a year or two later, Jack met another young woman, his present life, his name is Barbara.
And he met her in Blackwells at Oxford. She was where she was.
I don't know what her background is, but she was working in the store there in Blackwells.
And they hit it off immediately. She's a beautiful girl.
And they were married, and they have, I think they have two children.
So Jack, at the end of this period in Britain, you may have all this unrecorded, but you want me to tell you what I know about it.
His future career was Dorothy Hodgkin, of course, had worked in the structure of vitamin B12, and had determined its structure,
and had presented this as a plenary lecture at a meeting from how happened to be there,
and she got a standing ovation for this, and she later won the Nobel Prize for her work.
Well, this lecture or other work that she had been doing with Arcanic molecules, impressed the people in the organic,
I don't know whether it's a college or a school or whatever division, at the Ateha in Zurich,
and they asked her to recommend somebody who could be in organic chemistry, who could determine structures, and she recommended Jack.
Well, he went there, table lecture, showed what he was doing, and the upshot of all this was, say, hire them as a faculty member.
Well, he's had a distinguished career there. He's just widened his horizons immensely, became a professor,
which in the Old German system is about the equivalent of the well-regarded senator in this country, you know.
And Spenny's entire career at Zurich is now retired, but I think he still has an office, although I'm not sure what he's doing.
Occasionally, I run across him in this country, and I write to him occasionally also.
So, he is a reputation grew by leaps and bounds he's of foreign associate of the National Academy of Sciences,
and he gave the Baker lectures at Cornell, that's the same lecture series that Pauling gave that resulted in this book, The Nature, the Chemical Pond.
So, Jack's had a wonderful career. He's a very, very nice man.
Did he, does he have any major discoveries that you've known for, or is this the only thing that you've known for?
Well, it's a little hard to tell. Major discoveries in a scientific sense, he has a lot of distinguished, he has a distinguished publication record, not in the mouth,
but the sorts of things that he took up and studied thoroughly, basic science, it's very helpful to others.
But I don't follow Chris the log, if you're very closely, so I can't tell you much about what he has done.
I do know that he worked very hard on the confirmations of rings of various members in the rings, and there is elements of the rings, five, six, seven, eight, and more rings and so on.
He's well known for that.
I'd like to talk about Pauling it for a little bit. It doesn't sound like he, it sounds like he was certainly a person who spent time with others, but it often sounds like it's not in sort of a social way.
Yes, well, he wasn't anti-social at all. It's just that the kinds of parties of undescribing that many, but not all, the faculty attended, like, oh, I'm trying to think, for example, you mentioned Dan Campbell and Dick Badger and Werner,
and a number of other faculty members, as well as postdocs and graduates, so we all have a big party, you know.
Everybody was on a first-name basis. I never called Badger by anything other than his first name, even as a student. That's how he was known.
Almost everybody was on a first-name basis except with Pauling. He was always Dr. Pauling. He sort of carried an oral with him, and although he was friendly enough, you know, you didn't, you only came so far.
He always called me by my first name. Even on visits around here, I never really called him by his first name with any comfort at all, because he never invited it.
Now, I should tell you something. This is kind of going back to my stay in Norway. The person who headed up the laboratory on that first went there as a man named Old Hussle. He later won the Nobel Prize.
Hussle was a little bit about Hussle. He was an interesting man, and the Norwegian system then had professorships just like the German system. He was professor of physical chemistry, and there was a professor of organic chemistry, his name was Banner, and a professor of organic chemistry, these three groups.
But Hussle was unique. He was virtually, I don't know if I could call him an outright old vinyl, but he had very light features, very light hair, and he had kind of a nistagmas, and he had trouble reading.
He never married, and he had a lot of money that he inherited. He was a very good scientist. During the war, he was very aggressive, and he was imprisoned along with a couple of other people, and they were kept in a camp in Oslo.
They were not allowed to teach. The university was closed, but against all regulations in this camp, Hussle organized a series of lectures and studies, so the imprisoned people that actually learned a lot, while they were incarcerated from people who had lecture on topics, you see, they had been put in the camp with them.
So Hussle didn't knuckle under at all to the Germans. Well, in the war ended, and he went back, and resumed his position in Oslo. All the people who had been in the camp with him, he used the familiar form of the dress.
At that time in Norway, there were two words for you, which is do and see, or do rather, I'm thinking of German.
So he was D with of the old school, he was D with almost everybody that he didn't know, older people, especially they always referred to one of his D and D. Anyway, Hussle, after I had been there for a year and come back,
I would always make a point to go into see Hussle, because he was the professor. In effect, I think, a kind of a lonely man, because he had no family, he had a live in a huskkeeper who served him his meals and did everything around. I had a beautiful house.
And one time when I came in, I was always going to see him and we would shake hands, and he would go to the board and show me what he was working on. And then one time, when he was working at the board, and I had said D and so on, he was saying D, he turned to me and he said, this is traditional in Norway.
He said, we have known one another for a long time, I think it is time that we say, do to each other. Now, a younger man could never propose that. It had to be the older man. And of course, I was knowing Hussle was idea, I was quite honored by this, because here I was a foreigner, I was saying, do to him, or people that have been in his laboratory for years, that had not been in the camp right now.
And then one thing was still D. And these guys had been around for 20 years, he still said, D, you know. So, but anyway, I guess I probably hit it off with him because, of course, I always spoke Norwegian to him. And he was so pleased that an American would come and learn Norwegian.
Anyhow, he invited Lisa and me to dinner at his house on time. We went back to Norway after we were married. I've been there a couple of times on sabbatical leaves afterward. And one of these cases, he invited us to dinner. We had a magnificent dinner at his house.
It was all catered. He had ordered it in from the catering outfit. I think I say yes, actually. We're running a catering outfit. And we had a very pleasant evening at Hussle's house.
So...
The people didn't get to that TV level, it's calling very often.
Pardon? The people didn't get to the TV level, it's calling very often.
Not very often. It's a little hard to tell. I was kind of one way, as I said, you know. He always shook hands and said, how's Lisa doing? And he would ask me about her all sorts of things.
He would call me Ken, but I never felt that he relished me calling him Linus. And everybody had that feeling.
I know he visited here when Earl Gilbert was chairman and alive, and Gilbert referred to him as Linus. They talked to one another on that basis.
But I don't think Gilbert had really met him before. I just don't know.
The point is that he had a swing bowl that was playing popular there.
Yes. I haven't talked about that. I'll know. Well, here is a couple of incidents surrounding this woman.
I was asked by the Paulings with my then first wife to babysit the children while they were off on a trip.
The children were Peter, Linda, and Krillin. And they were early, early teens.
And Linus had finished and gone off to medical training, was often Linus junior in a white.
And so we weren't required to do anything that kids had to go to school, and so on.
We were supposed to be there in the evenings, make sure that they were all there, and so on.
And so we did that. And they had this swimming pool.
Paulings House had two wings that came together like this. And people were fond of saying, I'm not sure whether it's true or not, but the angle between the wings was 109 degrees in 28 minutes,
which is, of course, the angle, the tetrahedral bond angle.
I don't know whether that story is true or not, but it certainly was very close to it.
Well, down in the little below, the houses built slightly up and down below. They had a swimming pool.
And the Pauling kids, when their parents were away, were on the habit of going around the chemistry department, inviting everybody up to a big party in this swimming pool.
And I remember this happening one time. The pool was full of people and the Paulings showed up.
And in a short while, David Hilling came out and said, Linda, your father and I would like to take a swim. Can you get these people out of here?
There was a hush that fell over the group, and we vacated the premises very quickly.
One of the occasions when I was babysitting the kids, I heard a splash.
This is late at night. It was 11 o'clock, and I'd actually gone to bed, and a bedroom faced downhill.
But I couldn't really see this swimming pool clearly. I think I saw some ripples in it. And I heard this splash.
And I wondered what the hell that was. But anyway, I didn't bother to go out and check and so on.
And the next day, there was no sign of anything to lie. And on the second day, I also heard this splash in the pool.
And again, I did nothing about it, but in the morning I got up and I went into the kitchen and made my breakfast.
And there was a strange man standing there in the kitchen making breakfast.
And this was a guy. Again, the name is hard for me to come by, but a long standing friend of the Paulings and Paulings mentioned by name from the University of Texas.
And I guess they'd asked him if he'd like to stay there. Well, pardon me.
Yeah, that's right, Jeffress.
So we introduced ourselves to each other. It turned out we've been living in this house. Both of us for three days.
And this was the first time our paths had crossed. I usually got up early and sold it by then.
And then she went to work and I went to Caltech. And he probably was on vacation, came up later.
So we've been living for three days with almost third day that I met this guy in the same house.
Lloyd Jeffress, that's right. So that was the swimming pool.
What do you recall about the children's personality?
They were very, very vivacious. And Lynn also, Krillin, less so he was younger, quite a bit younger.
Well, I don't know how much younger, but at any rate, the two older ones, they were almost unfettered.
I mean, they were just in everything in a good, humid way. Very vocal both of them.
Many years later, I went to Lisa and I went to Europe.
And Peter at that time had gotten the position at the University of London, I guess it was.
And I called him and he met us in the sports car. By this time he had been pretty heavily into alcohols and big problems.
But at any rate, he was enthralled with my wife, Lisa, you know, and boy, he couldn't, he was sidelining up to her all the time and giving her all compliments.
She was laughing at him most of the time. Peter had trouble with, I think he had been divorced once.
And I don't remember any details of his life, I only knew at the end that he was totally in confidence and he had joined the Wales and was living in a small house.
I got a phone call from him a couple of times and Yale asking me about certain events in his father's life as a fellow named Herman Branson, who had given to him some problems regarding priority and discovery or ideas.
And so on, Peter had called me, I knew Herman Branson, for the line or anything about this and I didn't.
Well, Linda, I don't know a great deal about her life, how she went to college, what she did, I know.
She met Barclay when Barclay was a student at Caltech, Pauling was very impressed by Barclay.
I remember one occasion on a party when I was up there. He was asking Barclay some questions and Barclay was answering them and I guess he was, he decided that he was the guy for his daughter.
Again, that's just my reaction about it.
But Barclay was a nice guy and of course he lived in Pasadena and after we came to Corralis we didn't see them very much.
Barclay used to make an annual or biannual trip up to his glacier in Alaska, he was doing measurements on glacial flow and so on.
And one time they stopped by and they stayed overnight with us at a very pleasant evening and Barclay could play the piano quite well.
So he enjoys sitting at our piano and playing it during the evenings.
Afterward Linda asked her father for something that she could give to Lisa and me as a token of appreciation and I have a picture of Pauling together with all the famous artists.
Pauling was the famous African doctor and Dr. Albers Fightson.
And with both of them in the picture.
That was sent to me by Linda.
Would we reflect back on this period of Caltech?
Well, I guess it's probably termed because it was, you know, I was asked to give a lecture, a banquet talk one time at a meeting, a symposium in Texas.
And the topic suggested to me was the Golden Age at Caltech. That was a title of the talk.
So I dredged through all the archives and found out quite a lot about various people and things.
But the Golden Age was the age of all this marvelous stuff that Pauling was doing in chemistry and people like Feynman and others were doing it.
And it was an environment that couldn't be more exciting to a young student because you could almost literally hear a lecture each week by a Nobel Prize winner in some subject or another visitors.
I mean, I've heard lectures from people like Farmy who came from Argonne.
I've attended lectures by Feynman.
Carl Anderson was there. I've heard lectures by him.
And I've heard lectures by people in chemistry who came through.
So all this appeared when I was a student. And at the same time we knew there was a very active program, an ex-ray crystallography going on devoted to providing Pauling, quite sure, with the fundamentals of structure that would enable him finally to formulate the Alpha Helix.
They published seven papers. One of them is the Alpha Helix. That's the famous one. And there's a pleated sheet and a number of other things that they published at that time.
So all of this was going on. And we knew it.
And when Pauling finally unveiled his Alpha Helix, remember that was a lecture of some showmanship.
And I told you about that. No, well, Celtic built these space-filling models. You have some of them here in the special collection. Of the Alpha Helix, actually, I think.
And I think it was that same model, which is about this high. And it's got red, white, and black atoms all distributed through it, representing the various elements.
He started to give a lecture on this. And this thing was in the middle of the room, but it was covered with a tall paper bag. So he was going to describe the structure. And as he went on, people's curiosity got, they were getting more and more in the edge of his sheets. And he walked over and he pulled this thing up just a little about that far. And he put it down and says, oh, he said, I forgot to. And then people sort of twittered.
He did that once more, you know, when people laughed. And the third time, he took it off and showed it was everybody applauded. You see, he was a great showman in that respect.
I remember, by the way, a lecture he gave in quantum mechanics. I took, of course, in quantum mechanics from him. The room was quite full of students. He walked in one time. He carried a big book, which was the nature.
I'm sorry, introduction to quantum mechanics by him and Brian Wilson. And the normal copy is about that thing. But this is about that thing. It turns out that every facing page with blanks, we could write notes in it. And he would lecture from this. He would come in.
One day he walked in and as he got in, there was a, the room was very wide and had blackboards. They were blackboards in those days from one end to the other. He walked in, he put up a piece of chalk. And there were three panels here. He wrote on the upper left end corner, N-O-2.
Nitrogen dioxide. Without saying a word, he went across, he began to lecture and he filled up the board over here. And continues lecture, filled up the board over here. And as he got to the bottom, he had reached the point where he says, now you take an N-O-2 molecule and he pointed at whether it already put up the chair.
People the whole hour were wondering what was going to happen. But he headed at the precise location where he needed an illustration for what he had been talking about. And they had already written up there. That's the kind of subtle humor that he used to impress the students.
He gave lectures to the undergraduates too. And a lot of the undergraduates were a little bit unhappy with this. The better ones were not. The graduate teaching assistants of which I was one when I first came there were delighted with these lectures because they were what they were looking for.
But the students, he wouldn't pick out topics in the book and talk about them, the books booker itself. But he would talk about things associated with them that were involved at the, perhaps at the cutting level of research. And he would talk about this. And that kind of disappointed a lot of the students who wanted more explanation of what they were reading in the textbook.
Anyway, as TAs, we all like the lectures very much.
Well, is there anything else about the Caltech years that we should talk about?
I don't know. We've talked about a lot of the personalities there. There were a lot of people I haven't mentioned that figured prominently. For example, Jerry Donahue is a distinguished crystallographer.
And he happened to be in England in the same laboratory where Watson and Crick were. And he is said to have made a key observation to them about the configuration that played a big role in there eventually.
Coming to the right structure for DNA. There were other personalities I haven't mentioned in chemistry.
There were all sorts of names that run by, but I don't have anything particular to say about them. I did some work with a guy named Vernon Abaki from Switzerland.
He was a very, very impressive man named Edgar Halbunner. You know that name? Edgar came to Caltech also. He was a Jew that left Germany and had gone to Switzerland just ahead of the Nazis.
He was a superb scientist. He had a wonderful sense of humor. He taught me and my wife how to make cheese fondue.
And he became very, when back to Switzerland, roasted the ranks became a distinguished professor and went to Balsall. He and Jack Donahue were very close as families.
So they had apartments just a couple of doors away from each other. Edgar died a few years ago.
I had written to him when I knew that he was ill and I got a very nice letter back from him. A year and a half later I was going to write a game.
Then a fellow named Ishin Moser showed up to give a lecture in chemistry. I knew Ishin Moser. I had given a lecture and so I can...
Halbunner always spoke very highly of Ishin Moser. So I said, how was Edgar? He said, oh, he died. I was shocked. Absolutely shocked.
And so I talked to Jack Donahue about this running letter. So I hadn't heard at all. He apologized objectively for not having let me know.
At the end, Edgar became very discouraged about something. He had lost a leg in an accident. He probably knew all about that.
I'll tell you that in a minute. But he came very discouraged and he was in the hospital and finally, according to Jack, it appears as if he just gave up.
And he died in the hospital. And in spite of them being very, very close to families, I said, well, how is Ruth doing? That said, to her life.
He says, I don't know. He says it's amazing because she retreated into herself and has occupied herself solely with her children and grandchildren.
We haven't ever heard a word from her. And he was terribly surprised because they were very close and she was an open, friendly woman with a great sense of humor.
And maybe it just struck her so hard that she didn't want to have any connection with the past at all.
I wrote her a letter and I never had a response offering my condolences that Edgar was a very athletic guy, particularly in a rowing.
He was a single-score guy. He wrote on the lake in Zurich, but he was a budding scientist. And he told me all this.
He had been out on the town with his girlfriend and they had come by the house where he lived. It was an apartment up here on this hill when the tram came down like this.
One of these brand new Swiss trams that have all sorts of safety features on it.
He was standing waiting for the tram after having run upstairs to see whether the article he had been accepted had been published.
He was looking at a journal, you see. It had not been. And he came back down. He was standing on the platform with his then girlfriend.
And this tram came down the hill of the high-rated speed out of control and tipped over like this.
I don't know whether his companions survived that. And Ruth was not she. I think that's true. I think she was killed.
But at any rate, his body went through a window of the tram. But one leg was trapped underneath and they had damn-putated.
So when I met him, he was using a cane in the out of prosthetic device. He didn't use crutches. But he was brilliant at all sorts of alerts in Switzerland for a science later on.
It's hard for me to think about these people and knowing them as I did and then thinking about what would have happened to them.
Bad. So that's about all I can tell you. You know, there are many, many minor details. But those are the highlights of it all.
Okay. Well, we will go ahead and hold it for today.
Okay. You want to do more of this?
Yeah.
Okay.